[Musique]
alors moi je vais vous faire une
confession en fait
je suis une personne totalement
déséquilibrée
en tout cas je lis j'entends partout que
d'un côté il faut faire mille choses
dans sa vie pour la réussir mais que de
l'autre côté il faut
respirer ralentir pour être en équilibre
et ben merci merci non mais c'est super
moi continue ce que vous faites c'est
génial moi j'adore les injonctions
contradictoires
je vous propose pour les quelques
minutes qui viennent qu'on parle de
notre quête d'équilibre notre quête de
bien-être et peut-être qu'on se
réconcilie avec nos déséquilibres
justement
je m'appelle Grégory Pouilly j'ai 45 ans
j'ai fait j'ai eu la chance de faire pas
mal de trucs dans la vie entre autres
j'ai créé un podcast qui s'appelle VLAN
j'aime bien cuisiner j'ai créé des super
amitiés j'ai eu des très belles
histoires d'amour des moins bonnes voire
des carrément pourri je vous rassure
mais mais je ne suis pas marié j'ai pas
encore eu d'enfant j'aime bien manger
donc même si c'est pas la cata j'ai pas
un corps Instagram en plus j'ai perdu
des cheveux donc la définitivement je
crois que c'est mort
mais demain mes 10 doigts mais je sais
pas en faire grand chose je vis à
Lisbonne je sais pas faire de surf bref
il y a mille choses que je voudrais
pouvoir faire mais
j'ai pas le temps
et pendant ce temps là quand je vais sur
Instagram je vois des gens qui cuisinent
trop bien des gens qui bricolent trop
bien des gens qui s'occupent trop bien
de leur plante des gens qui ont des
enfants trop mignons ça génère beaucoup
de like les enfants des gens qui eux ont
un corps instagrammable ça aussi ça
génère du like
et on a beau me dire qu'Instagram c'est
pas la vraie vie c'est quand même super
dur de pas se comparer c'est un peu
comme si la cité me disait pas d'être
bon dans une chose dans 10 choses à la
fois mais des demandes en mille choses à
la fois et de jongler avec tout ça
mais vous avez déjà vu vous un hamster
qui compte dans sa roue comme ça et puis
qui saute d'une roue à l'autre et puis
qui jongle et puis il respire
et puis il fait le poirier parce qu'il
faut être en équilibre moi j'ai jamais
vu personne faire le poirier dans une
qui tourne jamais alors en conséquence
de ça moi j'ai pas mal d'amis qui
deviennent soit coach soit prof de yoga
j'imagine que pour vous c'est pareil le
problème c'est qu'une société uniquement
constituée de coach et de prof de yoga
ça marche pas très bien alors du coup
vous avez un job qui vous permet de
finir les fins de moi mais est-ce que ce
job vous plaît est-ce qu'il répond à vos
aspirations profondes et ce qu'il a du
sens est-ce qu'il est écolo et puis
surtout est-ce que vous arrivez le bon
équilibre entre vie pro vie perso et là
je parle que de boulot mais je pourrais
parler de votre vie familiale votre vie
amicale votre vie amoureuse votre
relation au sport votre relation à la
nourriture est-ce que je pourrais pas
avoir tout ça
et être en équilibre
moi je suis pas du tout surpris quand je
vois que les applications les plus
téléchargées sur les smartphones sans
des applications de productivité c'est
logique
mais je vous rassure à tout ça à toutes
ces injonctions contradictoires on a
trouvé la réponse vraiment c'est une
réponse assez magique et je suis assez
touché de vous la porter ce soir si vous
la connaissez pas déjà
ça s'appelle l'optimisation
l'optimisation
on est vraiment des pigeons quand même
non
non mais vous savez vraiment les pigeons
peuvent créer des superstitions en 1948
fredex Skinner qui est un psychologue
américain a fait des expériences sur des
pigeons dans un premier temps les pions
sont dans des cages c'est assez simple
et pour manger doivent actionner un
levier et puis dans un deuxième temps
ils doivent réagir un signal avant
d'actionner le levier mais dans un
troisième temps et c'est beaucoup plus
vicieux la nourriture arrive de manière
complètement aléatoire et là le pigeon
il est complètement perdu il essaye de
créer du sens mais en fait il y en a pas
donc en fait il va développer des
croyances par exemple si sauter avec le
pied au moment où la nourriture arrive
il va se dire peut-être qu'il y a un
lien de cause à effet donc il va sauter
comme ça que le pied de manière
frénétique pareil si battait des ailes
ou s'il remuait le coup en fait il a
créé des superstitions
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser à cette
blague je sais pas si vous la connaissez
est-ce que vous savez pourquoi les
danses de la pluie fonctionnent
tout simplement parce qu'il danse
jusqu'à ce qu'il pleuve
c'est logique
et nous à la manière d'épuisement de
merci
et nous à la manière des pigeons de
Skinner on a aussi créé des
superstitions et en particulier celle
que pour faire face à toutes ces
informations contradictoires on devait
optimiser non mais vraiment même ceux
qui veulent ralentir veulent une méthode
pour le faire rapidement
aucun sens mais en même temps qui n'a
jamais cherché une méthode pour maigrir
rapidement à prendre une langue
rapidement en faire ci faire ça
rapidement moi-même j'ai un podcast et
c'est de l'optimisation ça permet
d'apprendre de se divertir en faisant
autre chose en même temps
moi il y a une phrase dont j'ai horreur
mais que je me retrouve à dire quand
même de manière assez régulière
malheureusement c'est
oh là là
tellement occupé j'ai pas le Time mais
vous savez je le dis quand même avec ce
petit soupçon de fierté parce que l'air
de rien si je suis si occupé c'est que
je te suis occupé à réussir ma vie
et là je me dis mais
à quel moment on a créé une société dans
laquelle ne plus avoir de vie c'est un
critère de succès
ça n'a aucun sens
bon alors moi comme je cherchais quand
même mon bien-être mon équilibre je me
suis dit que j'allais m'intéresser à une
nouvelle méthode ça s'appelle le
développement personnel alors j'ai lu
les livres essentiels les accords
toltèques l'instant présent Edgar tolé
les 7 blessures de l'âme et toute une
nuit il y a d'autres
et puis il y a 12 ans j'ai fait mon
premier cours de yoga j'étais à San
Francisco il faisait super beau j'étais
avec ma petite amie de l'époque
c'est une expérience inoubliable le soir
même je me suis retrouvé à l'hôpital en
pensant que je faisais une crise
cardiaque
en fait bon bah pas du tout j'avais
simplement travaillé des muscles
profonds qui sont collés au poumon et
qu'il est pressurisé de manière un peu
particulière
ça a beaucoup fait rire les médecins
qui m'ont laissé partir mon entre nous
je vous le dis ils m'ont laissé partir
en fait avec un doliprane voilà ça a
beaucoup fait rire ma petite amie de
l'époque aussi mais bon je me suis pas
découragé j'ai continué ma pratique
parce que je me suis dit que le yoga ça
me permet d'être plus souple d'abord et
puis aussi plus ancré plus posé plus
équilibré mais qui dit plus équilibré
dit aussi plus efficace au travail et
puis un peu plus tard je me suis mis à
la méditation dans cette même logique
plus posée plus ancrée plus équilibré
mais il y a un moment donné ça me
demandait tellement de travail tout ça
lecture les lectures le yoga la
méditation que ça finit par générer du
stress quand j'arrivais pas à le caler
dans mon agenda
mais en fait ça aussi c'était de
l'optimisation en même temps il y a pas
de surprise donc développement personnel
déjà il est marqué développement et un
bon indice et puis après il y a marqué
une nouvelle source de culpabilisation
parce qu'en réalité ce sont des
nouvelles choses à ajouter sur la to do
listes de la personne supposée et
équilibrée en particulier si vous suivez
les dictats d'Instagram
d'ailleurs c'est assez intéressant quand
vous dites que vous méditez les
premières questions qui arrivent sont
des questions de performance ah oui mais
combien de temps mais combien de fois
par semaine
alors évidemment le développement
personnel pris comme ça ça ne fonctionne
pas ça peut éventuellement faire de vous
une personne plus optimisée sans doute
moins riche ça c'est sûr mais surtout
beaucoup plus coupable en fait
d'ailleurs en parlant que tuabilité qui
utilise des applications de tracking je
sais pas moi tracking de vos pas de
votre sport je sais pas de votre
nourriture de votre sommeil
moi mon péché mignon c'est le tracking
de mes pas j'avoue c'est pas très c'est
un peu honteux mais je sors toujours
avec mon téléphone voir parfois je
marche tout seul chez moi avec mon
téléphone
et je me fais des moyennes hebdomadaires
mensuelle annuelle en fait c'est un peu
comme si je m'intéressais moi à comment
je me sens et plus à ce que mon
téléphone dit de moi en réalité est-ce
que j'ai vraiment marché si mon
téléphone me dit autre chose
alors je voudrais juste faire un petit
rappel qui me semblait essentiel
il n'y a rien de vertueux à se torturer
pour être plus performant et plus
optimisé même s'il s'agit d'optimiser
votre développement personnel en fait ça
c'est juste la meilleure route pour
faire un burn out
en fait la quête d'équilibre ou la quête
de bien-être par la performance et
l'optimisation c'est une illusion
d'équilibre il y a rien à cet endroit
mais bon moi comme je cherchais toujours
j'ai eu évidemment beaucoup de
conversations dont une avec un ami à moi
qui s'appelle Olivier Morel
et Olivier m'a posé une question assez
centrale il m'a dit mais travailler plus
ok mais pour gagner quoi exactement
et alors tu réfléchis je savais pas
Olivier il avait un bon poste dans une
grosse boîte française et un jour il a
une promotion il a décidé de passer à
mi-temps donc du coup il a évidemment
divisé son temps de travail par deux
mais il a aussi divisé sur son salaire
par deux il a divisé sans cash flow et
lui ce qui m'explique c'est que il a
augmenté sans rien flow sans lecture
flow son ami Flo son surf flow son
chemin de Compostelle Flo en fait il
avait changé ses indicateurs
et là peut-être vous vous dites oui mais
c'est Olivier là il va avoir un salaire
en béton pour pouvoir le diviser en deux
c'est vrai il avait un salaire au-dessus
de la moyenne mais en fait rien de
faramineux non plus et puis dans le coin
de mes conversations j'ai aussi la
chance de rencontrer Fred avec Lopez
vous savez c'est le journaliste qui a
entre autres créé et animé rendez-vous
en terre inconnu Fred il a eu évidemment
plein de conversations dans sa vie dont
une avec un agriculteur qui avait perdu
l'intégralité de sa récolte en raison du
changement climatique et pourtant
l'homme souriait et donc Fred il
interloqué il comprend pas donc il pose
la question à l'homme il lui dit mais
comment tu arrives à sourire alors que
tu viens de tout perdre et en
particulier de quoi te nourrir et
nourrir ta famille et l'homme lui répond
tout simplement parce que je sais qu'une
personne de ma communauté sera là pour
m'aider
je crois que on a fait fausse route en
fait on a confondu bien vivre et
bien-être
tout ce qu'on s'est vertu à accumulé à
performer à optimiser ça nous permet
d'accéder à ce que nous on appelle dans
la société occidentale vous moi le
succès le succès pour vous pour moi
c'est effectivement l'accumulation de
bien de pouvoir d'argent mais ça c'est
du bien vivre c'est pas du bien-être en
fait et moi j'avoue que acheter pour
acheter posséder pour posséder même si
je suis toujours dans ce mode de
fonctionnement à vous tromper pas je
suis pas au dessus je suis toujours là
mais ça me porte plus vraiment
et généralement quand je dis ça on me
dit oui mais Greg quand même je peux pas
nier t'accumuler de l'argent c'est aussi
accéder à une forme de liberté bien sûr
et vous savez quoi c'est vrai c'est
beaucoup plus facile de vivre avec de
l'argent que ça évidemment 1000 fois
mais parce que je sais j'ai des potes
qui ont vendu des startups je sais que
parfois l'argent ça vous en présente
généralement quand je dis ça me dit oui
mais Greg toi t'as pas d'enfants mais
faut penser quand même à l'héritage
qu'est-ce qu'on va leur laisser et bien
sûr évidemment les enfants ils ont
besoin d'un bon cadre pour pouvoir se
développer correctement mais moi je
crois que ils ont plus besoin de temps
d'amour d'intelligence émotionnelle pour
s'épanouir dans la vie en réalité
en réalité pour moi l'équilibre c'est
pas cette situation parfaite géniale de
laquelle je ne bouge pas ça c'est de
l'inertie en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est un
équilibre qui est dynamique c'est à dire
un déséquilibre permanent en réalité un
peu comme quand je marche je suis en
déséquilibre permanent vous avez déjà vu
un enfant qui apprend à marcher c'est
hyper mignon et qui tube c'est pas
facile parfois il peut tomber mais
pourtant il avance
et en fait la nature c'est pareil c'est
un déséquilibre permanent mais qui crée
quelque chose qui me semble encore plus
beau que l'équilibre c'est l'harmonie
j'ai pas prévu de vous donner de
conseils certainement pas je vais pas
non plus vous faire la leçon mais je
voudrais juste partager trois choses que
j'ai décidé de faire pour moi
la première c'est d'envoyer bouler cette
logique de performance et d'optimisation
et moi j'avoue que dès que je sens que
j'ai le besoin je fais la sieste ça
arrive quasiment tous les jours du coup
la deuxième chose c'est de m'éloigner au
plus possible c'est jamais complètement
possible de la vie des autres et de leur
injonction contradictoire j'essaye
d'être connecté à moi-même à mes côtés
lumineux mais aussi à mes côtés sombres
et c'est comme ça qu'il y a 10 ans j'ai
décidé de me lancer en indépendant parce
que en réalité j'ai laissé tomber les
titres et les grosses boîtes et toute la
reconnaissance sociale qui va avec
et puis la troisième
j'ai décidé de me donner la liberté
d'être moi-même en fait quand j'ai lancé
mon podcast c'était il y a 5 ans et
c'était un podcast de marketing moi je
suis marketeur donc ça me permet
simplement de trouver des nouveaux
clients ça c'est logique et puis il y a
4 ans j'ai décidé d'en faire un podcast
sur l'évolution de la société alors bien
sûr ce podcast ne me permet plus du tout
de trouver de nouveaux clients en même
temps ça tombe bien parce que j'ai plus
du tout envie de faire le marketing pour
des raisons écologiques
mais par contre cet acte politique comme
j'aime l'appeler il me ressemble
beaucoup plus
j'ai tatoué sur mon bras
une phrase qui me rappelle tout ce que
je viens de vous raconter c'était il y a
13 ans et je l'ai tatoué précisément à
cet endroit là juste là parce que ça me
permet de la lire de manière assez
régulière et en même temps finalement
généralement les gens voient même pas
que je suis tatoué
cette phrase c'est ce moment aussi
passera
et cette phrase elle me rappelle
l'impermanence des choses du bonheur du
malheur de la joie de la tristesse en
réalité de l'impermanence de la vie
parce que si vous vous sentez en
déséquilibre c'est que vous vous sentez
vivant donc la seule chose que
j'aimerais que vous repartiez avec ce
soir c'est simplement que vous
embrassiez vos déséquilibres en fait que
vous les revendiquez merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]